there's this YouTube comment and it has
like 28 000 likes and for the last five
years I haven't been able to stop
thinking about it so yeah nestled under
the animated music video entitled
Sparkle from Makoto shinkai's 2016 anime
smash hit your name the comment reads I
consider thinking long and hard about
what I thought and felt watching this
movie I'm an animator and was initially
drawn to this film because of its art
Direction I'm very glad I paid it the
attention I now know that it deserved I
moved away from my home to Japan over
ten thousand kilometers from the girl I
love what this movie does white
masterfully is concentrate and draw
attention to what we really need as
people instead of writing his name he
wrote something much more important for
her to know something I didn't see
coming and I think that highlights what
this movie has done for so many people
remind them of what's most important I
booked a flight home back to my
girlfriend I need to hug her and tell
her these things
alright so that comment is pretty out
there but the reason why I think about
it all the time is because I was the one
who wrote it this is my story of how
Makoto shinkai is your name literally
changed my entire life
[Music]
I think before I get all vulnerable up
in here I should say that none of what
I'm about to share is advice I've been
sitting on this video trying to figure
out how best to present it for years now
but I've never been ready to sticking to
my tried and true method of delving into
the minutia of the narrative to reveal
some deeper meaning seems like a safe
idea for this Venture but I'm not going
to do that with this video this film has
been covered to death from all angles
over the last several years it feels
like Makoto shinkai shared a piece of
his soul in the production and writing
of it so I think it's only fair that I
too offer up a piece of me that I've not
yet shared publicly for the longest time
this comment acted as the only digital
evidence documenting what was and still
is the single most pivotal moment of my
life a comment that seemed to resonate
with tens of thousands and one I posted
reactively following my viewing of the
film your name a comment that was
inspired by one specific aspect of this
story
when I was seven years old I met a girl
it was on my very first day of martial
arts class and she was the same age as
me I'm quite extroverted and that
translated into me being quite annoying
when I was younger but it never bothered
her the same way that it bothered other
people we became fast friends and it
remained that way until we went our
separate ways to college life got in the
way and I didn't see her for years after
that treasured the experience dreams
will fade when you wake for me this
quote meant seizing the moment for you
never know when your chance to do so
will vanish and this sentiment is echoed
everywhere in the movie especially the
opening the first visual we see in this
film tells this exact story initially we
see a shooting star Fantastical and
dreamlike in all of its Splendor however
it is quickly contrasted by the harsh
reality it brought to the world in a way
childhood innocence convinces us that we
can do anything become anything and find
someone that will sweep us off our feet
or accept us for who we really are and
sometimes somehow along the way we get
beaten down disillusioned and let down
by reality over and over again and in
the process start to ignore and lose
hope that there's anything magical out
there at all and before I even watch
this film after having failed out of
college after scraping together a minor
animation qualification and no clear
path forward I think I was starting to
feel that exact way now there's a
character that's not too often spoken
about in this film but one I regretfully
could see myself a lot in mitsa's Father
symbolizes what happens to those who are
beaten down by life sometimes grim and
harsh realities a man who lost his spark
for Life his connection to his daughters
and his wider family following the
sudden death of his wife and meets his
mother but this film isn't so much about
bucking conventions and traditions but
more so listening to yourself like
really listening to yourself not to
starve your soul of what it needs
because of convention but to instead
find a balance between what you've been
dreaming about and the limitations that
reality inevitably will present without
losing one in favor of the other
entirely and the animation style in many
respects reflects this too all over this
film The Real World as well as the more
abstract and dreamlike sequences are all
given equally gorgeous touches however
when one is favored over the other then
things feel more static lifeless in the
case of reality Roto scope is used in
this film and sort of creates this
perfect philosophical marriage of these
ideas for those that don't know
rotoscope is the practice of tracing
over real life footage to create
animation and by doing so make shukes of
reality but doesn't limit itself to it
creating a result greater than the sum
of its parts and at this point in the
film I still didn't feel like I could
have had what I wanted or that I even
deserved it with only one week before I
left for Japan I reached out to that
girl to say goodbye one last time and
once we did after several hours of
having an amazing time talking together
we expressed our feelings for each other
this could have been the last time we
ever saw each other after all so we made
the most of it and with that in mind one
day prior to the flight I handed her one
sealed letter with her name on it I told
her to promise me that she would never
open it until I said it was okay to she
agreed and just like that I was gone I
was enraptured by this idea of finding
success that would make up for my
supposed failings at the time I didn't
have any meaningful successes to speak
of I didn't even have really any money I
spent it all trying to get to Japan and
now I was living in a tiny apartment on
the other side of the world sitting on a
tiny table with my laptop watching this
film and as the story began to ramp up
towards its climax this happened
[Music]
there's a moment in this film where Taki
realizes that he missed his chance that
he acted too late realizing that mitsuha
as well as everyone in itamori had
perished its horrific natural disaster
but one that emphasizes the special time
limit we can all take for granted in the
film's second half Taki box convention
in the name of seeking out who he's
starting to accept is someone he has a
connection with unlike anyone he's ever
met before and through exploring any and
all options available to him stumbles
into a second chance mitsuha on the
other hand needs to confront her father
the embodiment of someone who was broken
down by the harsh realities of life
itself and in the very finish of the
film Taki unsure if he's experienced a
dream and unsure of anything he's felt
has any bearing in reality at all passes
mitsu her one last time and instead of
going with the flow instead of biting
his lip he takes a chance
for two long months I lived in Japan
alone until one fateful day for whatever
reason I decided to check out this film
and as soon as it ended all my
insecurities and uncertainties suddenly
evaporated I knew I had made a terrible
decision I raced to my computer
purchased the next flight home went
straight to her house called her on her
mobile and told her to look outside when
she did I said that it was now okay to
read that letter what did it say that is
something that I want to keep private so
I'm Gonna Leave You guess for that one
now some of you might be saying you
can't leave us there what happened next
what did she say in the end after all of
that was it worth it
I can confidently say I have never made
nor will I ever make a better decision
than the one that I made on that day
[Music]
oh yeah